President Biden taking some heat over
what critics say is a slow effort to get
Americans out of Harm's Way in Israel
the Biden Administration is now
reversing course after Mr Kirby told
Americans trying to get out of Israel
that they should fly
commercial first of all commercial
flights are still going in and out of
Ben garan airport so that's always an
option for those who may want to leave
there are still some viable ground
routes uh and we're exploring many other
options as well uh uh to see if there's
other things that we can do to help
Americans who want to leave starting
tomorrow the US government will be
offering charter flights for Americans
to get out judge um your thoughts on on
Mr Kirby's the commercial flight line
was that give them the benefit of the
doubt I like to give people the benefit
of the doubt but what are your thoughts
on that and whether or not the flight
should have been started sooner the
charter flights what do you think my
thoughts are based on the look on your
face I
think look look I mean there are some
airlines that are not flying to Israel
now so I mean how can you possibly
expect the Israelis to get on a an
airplane a commercial plane we should
have been in there as my friend was on
Sunday with his plane as some of the
veterans have been on their planes and a
congressman who is it coryy Cory Mills
yeah I mean look we're Americans we
don't wait for people to ask we just do
it Dana well I permission to uh give
some advice to the comms people at the
White House power and there's two things
that they've done where I think that
they could have done a better job since
Saturday because basically the people
that that are above them in terms of
leadership or in the chief of staff's
office or National Security Council they
are not giving the Press people what
they need in order to do things that are
just logical for example on the charter
flights on Sat I would never have gone
out there and knowing that I was going
to get that question without being able
to say yes there will be charter flights
and the way you do that is you go to the
chief of staff's office and say I'm
going to get this question the president
is going to be criticized just like he
was in the Afghanistan withdrawal and I
don't want to do that I want to protect
the president and I want to get the
Americans out so can you call whoever we
need to call and tell them we need the
flights and then I will go out and do
the briefing okay the second thing they
should have done is on Saturday when
they were going to get the question
about the six billion say I'm not going
out there until I can say that those
funds will be frozen well guess what
today they're saying yeah actually
Treasury Department saying what like
we're we're not going to give any of
that money out they could have said that
Saturday so the communications people do
have the ability and the power to push
things if they want to I hope someone
was listening uh bill you have strong
thoughts about this too I ronto sandis
announced that he's goingon to fly some
planes to um yeah Israel and and bring
Floridians back they also said there are
more than 20,000 Americans who want to
leave Israel I I haven't seen that
number quoted anywhere else the White
House did not give out that number to
not of the state department uh two
things here three hours ago India
announced that it had its first flight
out of Israel with 2112 citizens on
board and Hungary has had two flights
for 325 citizens and one ship to Cypress
already with 65 citizens on board so
look I trust the American government to
get this done the right way but I I do
agree maybe we should have stepped on
the gas Afghanistan you still have faith
has a Gutfeld flown over Greg to to get
anybody to bring yet it's only private
just me uh but they this Administration
does seem eternally surprised by things
whether it's the six billion or the pull
out or the effects of like defunding the
police or abolishing cash bail or
legalizing theft which creates more
theft or elevating Sanctuary cities to
sa Hood to them cause and effect is like
a foreign concept you know how did I get
this hangover to them you know that
fiery ball in the sky every morning is
heading our way but we know it's the sun
they just and they just can't understand
why things are so expensive when you
print more money it just seems like
they're always behind the you know
behind the curve on everything but I
hope I'm wrong but I'll be right hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else